alright guys you ready dark zone yep I
just got a mask upgrade I want to try it
out in there and get us some good sweet
let's do it
remember when we get in there it might
not be just us
I'm activated system rebooted
all right now Jim go ahead careful
I see you've got three or four Rikers
looks like level 11 an assault a sniper
and the rusher there's you should take
the lead I'll follow
yeah students quickly okay cool
everybody ready
yeah let's see some teamwork other
players they have darks on booth should
he go for it
I don't know we can't take that man the
right goes at the same time good fine
let's just see what they do
oh they're going records what's happen
out all right go I'm gonna flank it go
Bryant cover us
heads up heads up you turn it okay
towards up get down I got [ __ ] on the
left
good
nice nice
most house neutralized proceed with
caution
all right Brian you want to check out
the crate let's see what these dead guys
have
yeah it's do it
nice job nice all right where to
well--that's extract at Bryant Park
that's pretty close okay you lead the
way all right
looks like these other guys are coming
with us
[ __ ] cleaners what's taken out that's
too risky
they're all elite let's try not to pull
aggro what you have is five of us with
loot that we want to hold on to trust me
follow me around this way okay right
gotcha
Brian how's it look
all right all clear let's spread out
keep it looking up guys I'm gonna call
it in okay got you covered
we're all clear let's extract okay we
got 90 seconds
keep your eyes peeled everyone
do you see anything no I can't help
thinking what these guys have thought
that leave it yeah what do you think we
got
alright there it is get ready let's get
the goods out of here
no but seriously should we take care of
these guys yeah three of us and two of
them well we got 60 seconds I say we do
it Brian you game all right
here comes a sticky on my mark
protocol we keep doing the left there
all right I got her running lawn house
from the division dance down down right
can you help them out
I'm leading Zoey
fifteen seconds Ryan what are you
waiting for do it clock's ticking let's
go
hostile neutralized